i feel like i'm playing house yeah and
we are
we are
[Music]
i love that both of us have such
parallel lives um i'll give
a few examples off the top of my head
we both got our entire lives
change slash start with steven spielberg
right you did penny marshall's first
movie
yeah i did penny marshall's last movie
um we both have been married three times
which by the way sidebar when i had to
show up on the set of boys on the side
and tell you i got married over the
weekend i would talk about
shame i was like yeah no i wasn't really
talking about this guy last week but i'm
married to him now
so happy monday and say yeah
i was i was embarrassed um because i
care about what you think
um but then i've done it also
pretty much the same way hey yes i'm
here
yeah no no i did get married yeah what's
his name
wait a minute i know it but let's finish
what you're talking about and then we'll
we'll get to what his name is yeah it's
a real how was your weekend moment
and it was films and experiences like
boys
on the side that they were so
you called me that was a miracle thank
you for asking me to be a part of that
extraordinary movie
it was wild wasn't it we had something
just a little bit
different i think whether it was my
brother driving us
wherever we were trying to get to or
you know just behaving a little
a little wildly and having a blast and
knowing we had each other's backs
the thing that also is so important and
you
are someone who really instilled this in
me
um which was that you can be as wild
rebellious
have a past you know get married over a
weekend
whatever it is but the kindness
the goodness the
that is the consistent through line and
living a life where you get to be
yourself and you get to do your thing
and figure your stuff out
but you're so good to people
it's that's who i followed that's who
i've learned from
and you are the living example of that
and that film i
i associate you with dry skin i know
this is such a weird thing
but because i had really dry skin and
you you heard me and the next day you
came in with a tub of shea butter
you are the best listener and i was like
she heard me say i have dry skin and she
delivered
shea butter every time i moisturize i
think of you um
we both started out in acting
and comedy and have now found ourselves
in the daytime space yes
yes listen i i got
very listen i got very very lucky
because i got into some
trouble uh where i pissed off
a politician and then i lost everything
really i lost
my ability to make a living i lost uh
any kind of you know things that i had
going on that
you know would bring money and so i
didn't work for five years
and barbara walters god bless her
said um i need another person would you
ever consider and i was like yes because
i'd gone through all my savings you know
taking care of your family you go
through everything you every everything
is sitting on you
and so i went through everything and um
she gave me a job which has lasted 10
years now which you know i'm really
grateful for
when you find yourself in your next
chapter sometimes it's something that
you didn't anticipate um but i still
feel like there was probably a lot of
work behind
it that generated the karmic
moment of that opportunity like when
barbara walters
called you and this woman elaine bauer
brooks
at cbs called me but we've
been in film and television
for so many years and watched it and
loved it and been a part of it
i've always been on television i've
always done
movies like it's yeah maybe it was a
perfect fit
for both of us i think so listen i think
the fact that we're working because
we're both
workaholics you know you you always have
to have a gig
we're not ones to sit back and say well
you know i've done it all
you're uh a moderator
and you're watering the garden of these
other women do you feel like
that everybody needs equal water and
light
and tending to in order to have that
garden
thrive well i
i believe that that you always in a
garden have to have variety
and so you must make sure that
variety can thrive there now there are
some things like there's some things i
will never eat like i'm never gonna eat
a radish
but i like to make sure they're in the
garden i like to make sure they're there
i like my corn i like some broccoli
but you know i i i don't like artichokes
but i got friends who do so i always
make sure they're in the garden as well
so for me the garden
is life really that's what you need in
your life
you can't just have the same thing in
your garden
because it's requiring that you pay
attention to stuff that has nothing to
do with what you're really interested in
but in order to be part of the real
conversation of the world
you've got to be paying attention you've
got to be awake but i'm wondering how i
as a singular individual can help
represent
those different viewpoints except them
have them on the show so that if people
ever tune into this um because
i'll never assume they will i'll just be
happy if they do
that they will feel welcomed there
listening is everything because if you
make it
if you give people the
the ability to say what they need to say
what they want to say and just listen to
them
it allows them to relax and whether it
is a
a viewpoint that you agree with if they
feel unattacked you know
if they feel not like you're judging
you're just listening you're you and the
people you've brought
with you are listening and
sometimes you'll want to say are you out
of your
freaking mind but you don't
those important meaningful complex
conversations is
more vital and more necessary than ever
and making people
feel heard and respected for their
differences
i feel like from there maybe we could
get
somewhere and maybe that's idealistic
and naive
but i i i have never approached anything
in life
not believing that it's my core belief
in fact frankie my daughter
who's six we were in the bath or she was
in the bath i was sitting there
and um she said why are we here
and i said do you mean like right here
in this bathroom right now
or you know and she was like no
why are we alive and i said
oh like you want to know the meaning of
life
and she was like yes and i was okay
um and i in a very
spiritual interesting kind of way there
was only one answer that came to me and
nothing
could get in its way nothing else came
and it was we're here to take care of
each other
have no other answer nothing will come
this is so strong
that it's not allowing anything else to
come in
so i think
i want to take that with me in this
um well don't forget there is that you
have to include
this other piece to that we're here to
take
care of each other and ourselves and
have
as good a time as we can
because you must
i feel children must be allowed to be
children do you think this job helped
make you feel more like a grown-up well
it certainly helped people treat me more
like a grown-up
that's what it did because suddenly they
were like oh i didn't hadn't thought
about that and i was like well
actually neither had i but you know this
is what came out of my mouth
so you have a lot of hats you are the if
you think about it
like in the old days you are the weather
person you are the news anchor
you are the uh special events
person you've got to do all of those
things you have to bring
all of that in this 43-minute
segment so you have to you have to have
as much
fun as you possibly can with this show
because the
the reason people are going to watch it
is for you
they want to know what you're doing they
want to know who
who's talking to you this day you're
going to have a great time
i'm telling you just you know pace
yourself but you'll be fine
i am so happy to have had this excuse
to check in with you and say hello and
tell you how much i love you
and i'm just i'm so happy to see you
you oh i love you more